bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du Sénat pour la séance de cet
après-midi est consacrée au vote de la
première partie du projet loi de
finances pour 2014 première partie qui
porte sur les recettes du budget de
l'État et une première partie du PLF
2014 qui va sans doute être rejetée cet
après-midi par le Sénat en effet depuis
une semaine maintenant et bien les
sénateurs ont détricoté cette partie
recette supprimant des impôts des taxes
et le PLF première partie donc sur les
recettes ne ressemble plus à grand-chose
selon le gouvernement mais aussi selon
les différents groupes politiques du
Sénat ce qui devrait donc d'entrer
d'emblé entraîner pardon son rejet cet
après-midi alors tout de suite on va
rejoindre tamtranui qui se trouve dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat avant de l'entendre
pour voir un petit peu comment vont se
dérouler les explications de vote sur ce
PLF 2014 on va écouter à l'instant cet
hommage qui commence c'est celui de
Jean-Pierre Bell le président du Sénat
qui rend hommage à Lucien nevirz celui
qui a porté la loi sur la pilule qui est
un ancien sénateur on écoute Jean-Pierre
bal et on revient après sur le budget
saluer le courage et la lucidité du
jeune homme je dirais même de
l'adolescent qui enterra dans la
Résistance à 16 ans arrêté par la police
de Vichy il s'enfuit en Espagne avant de
rejoindre Londres fait prisonnier lors
d'une mission au
Pays-Bas promis à l'exécution sonmaire
comme ses camarades il en ressort
grivement blessé mais miraculeusement
vivant engagé auprès du Général de
Gaulle pour la libération de la France
c'est dans les rang Gaulistes qui
commence sa carrière politique d'abord
comme Benjamin du conseil municipal de
sa ville natale Saint-Étienne puis comme
adjoint au maire c'est là qu'en
1957 il fait la connaissance du
mouvement maternité heureuse qui
deviendra le Mouvement français pour le
planning
familial porte-parole du comité de Salut
publique et directeur de radio ALG au
cours des derniers mois de la 4e
République il est élu député de la 5 5e
République dès
1958 son œuvre de parlementaire inspiré
par la volonté de faire évoluer le droit
pour mieux assurer et promouvoir la
humaine celui qui disait avoir été élevé
par deux femmes
exceptionnelles reste marqué par le
courage de celles qui ont combattu à ses
côtés dans la
Résistance animé par une conscience
aigue de la situation parfois tragique
des femmes dans les années 50 et 60 il
affronte les conservatismes pour leur
apporter une liberté
essentielle en autorisant la
contraception la loi du 28 décembre
1967 qui porte son nom leur donne la
maîtrise de leur corps et de leur
fécondité violemment attaqué au cours de
ce qui fut un véritable combat
législatif Lucienne virt apporté une
contribution majeure à à l'émancipation
des femmes cet engagement il le poursuit
en tant que rapporteur à l'Assemblée
nationale du projet de loi de Simone
veille sur l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse en
1974 devenu président du Conseil général
de la Loire il est élu sénateur de 1983
à
2001 observateur avisé
sensible de la société il inscrit dans
la loi de nouvelles avancées pour que Ch
chacun soit un peu plus maître de son
destin face à la douleur et au drame de
la vie queur du Sénat membre éminant de
la Commission des affaires sociale il
prend l'initiative de deux textes qui
font progresser notre pays en matière de
prise en charge de la douleur et des
soins palliatifs il a accompli dans ce
domaine également une œuvre
fondatrice celui qui agit avec tant de
conviction tant de générosité et de
persévérance pour le bien commun pour
les droits des femmes et pour le respect
de la dignité humaine mérite notre
profonde reconnaissance à son épouse à
ses proches j'adresse en notre nom
toutes nos condoléances nos condoléances
les plus sincère mes chers collègues je
vous propose d'observer une minute de
silence à la mémoire de Lucien
virt
je vous
remercie bien je reprends no débat en
application de l'article 45 alignéa 2 de
la Constitution le Gouvernement engagé
la procédure accélérée pour l'examen du
projet de loi relatif à la isation et la
simplification du droit et des
procédures dans les domaines de la
justice et des affaires voilà donc pour
cet hommage du Sénat cet après-midi et
c'est hommage notamment du président du
Sénat Jean-Pierre B à Lucien nevirz
ancien sénateur celui qui a porté la loi
sur la pilule en France et puis ancien
grand résistant vous avez pu entendre le
discours de Jean-Pierre Bell alors on va
repartir sur des questions plus
budgétaire avec donc les explications et
le vote cet après-midi au Sénat sur la
première partie du projet loi finance
2014 on va tout de suite rejoindre dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat tranui bonjour
bonjour pine vous suivez pour nous ces
débats on en est où et ce vote devrait
intervenir à quel moment cet après-midi
alors les sénateurs s'apprêtent dans
quelques instants à aborder le titre 2
c'est-à-dire le titre relatif à
l'équilibre des ressources et des
charges donc plus globalement
l'équilibre général du budget donc c'est
un seul article qui précédera donc les
explications de vote puis le vote avant
ça toute cet après-midi ils ont examiné
assez rapidement tous les budgets
annexes et les comptes spéciaux
c'estàdire des sujets extrêmement divers
on a parlé des bonus malus automobiles
mais aussi de du financement des
infrastructures de transport des
relations financières entre l'État et la
sécurité sociale en abordant notamment
la question du financement du RSA et
puis ensuite il y a eu donc toute la
question épineuse du financement de
l'audiovisuel publ à présent donc les
sénateurs en sont à l'article 43 voilà r
ce que vous pouvez dire sur cette
séance merci beaucoup Tam on vous
retrouve en direct de l'émicycle à
différents moments de ses explications
de de vote et du vote cet après-midi au
Sénat alors je rappelle pour les
téléspectateur qui nous suivent et bien
que si le la première partie du projet
loi de finance pour 2014 est rejeté et
bien c'est l'ensemble du budget qui
tombe en effet si les recettes ne sont
pas adoptées et bien le Sénat
n'examinera pas la partie dépenses de ce
budget pourquoi le budget bien serait
rejeté par le Sénat aujourd'hui tout
simplement parce que ces différentes
mesures principales notamment les taxes
les recettes qui avaient été prévu par
le gouvernement n'ont pas été adopté en
tout cas les principales n'ont pas été
adopté par les sénateurs je pense à la
contribution exceptionnelle de 75 % euh
pour les personnes qui gagnent plus d'un
million d'euros par an je pense
également à la TVA qui te vait augmenter
pour les centrescass il y a eu un
amendement qui refuse l'augmentation de
de cette TVA qui a été adoptée par le
Sénat je pense également à la baisse du
cotient familial donc tout ça ce sont
des mesures qui ont été rejetées par les
sénateures et qui font que finalement
euh ni la majorité gouvernementale ne se
retrouve sur ce texte ni même euh
d'autres groupes de gauche comme les
communistes ne sont d'accord avec le
budget du gouvernement et puis bien sûr
l'opposition l'UDI l'UMP sont contre
également le budget du gouvernement si
bien que bah il pourrait y avoir
personne pour adopter cette première
partie du budget cet après-midi ou en
tout cas une partie des sénateurs
pourrait s'abstenir on va suivre ça tout
au long de cet après-midi je vous
propose tout de suite et bien de
rejoindre la séance Francis de Lat le
sénateur s'exprime et puis on va avoir
dans quelques instants donc les
explication de vote on reviendra ici
avec des invités pour vous faire suivre
cette séance en direct du Sénat tout à
l'heure certaines qui ont des charge
plus que d'autres nous avons ensuite
écarté la fiscalisation de l'avantage
complémentaire santé c'est un tour de
passe-passe on bien dire de l'ingénierie
financière qui peu à peu envahit nos
discussions car c'est 17 millions de
Français qui vont bénéficier très
avantagement de l'avantage
complémentaire santé est-ce utile de les
faire contribuer sur ce mince
avantage en l'imposant sur leur assiette
sur le revenu c'est vrai que ça coûte
1,2 milliards mais enfin quandême 17
millions de salariés c'est quand même
pas une fiscalité pour les riches ce
sont nos concitoyens qui travaille
ensuite le ministre du Budget nous a
indiqué que les entreprises pour l'année
prochaine allent diminuer leur charge
all diminuer d'environ 10 milliards
alors pour faire en sorte que cet
engagement soit vraiment tenu nous avons
fait en sorte d'écarter la
surfiscalisation de l'impôt sur les
sociétés les société de plus de 2500
millions de chiffres d'affaires et c'est
effectivement un coût pour le budget de
2,5 milliards nous rappelons quand même
que ça va mener le taux de l'impôt sur
les société à 38 % contre 15 % en
Allemagne 24 % en royaauuni et ensuite
nous sommes surpris de voir que dans le
rapport Gallois il peê indéqué que
c'était les les PME PMI qui ont déjà une
certaine consistance qui ont à peu près
les moyens d'entreprendre une campagne
de pour conquérir les marchés
internationaux donc si vous voulez que
nous renforcions la compétitivité de ces
entreprises qui sont ciblées par le
rapport Galois comme devant attaquer les
marchés internationaux il est bien
évident qu'il ne faut pas les surtaxé de
2,5
milliards nous avons ensuite écarté
encore une innovation financière funeste
qui remonte à 2013 et qui a été
accentuée en 2014 sur la non
déductibilité fiscale des intérêts des
prêts conclus par les entreprises pour
leurs investissements ça coûte
effectivement 3 milliards dans un pays
où 80 % des investissements des
entreprises sont assurés par les banques
une telle mesure ne conclut qu'à une
chose à augmenter le taux des emprunts
qu'ils ont don ils ont besoin pour
emprunter pour leurs investissements
tout le monde se plaint tout le monde
remarque que nous avons un véritable
problème dans les investissement des
entreprises et nous pensons que et au
lieu de les surtaxer là aussi il serait
plus utile à l'économie du pays et eu
égard aux faiblesses effectivement de
fonds propres de nos entreprises de les
aider plutôt que de les taxer ensuite
nous avons eu bien sûr alors ceci coûte
3 milliards donc nous sommes au 11
milliards tout à chacun peut juger de la
pertinence de nos amendements ils ont
été
parfois soutenu par un certain nombre de
de de groupes de l'opposition et nous
les en remercions pour le procès qui a
été fait à nos propres propositions je
dirais que si déjà nous faisions
exactement le contraire de ce que vous
nous avez
proposé ce serait déjà pas mal ce serait
déjà un début de programme ça ne
suffirait pas mais ce serait déjà le
début d'un
enfin pour les collectivités
territoriales 4 5 milliards prélevés en
2 ans 1,5 milliards d'économie sont
faites et quand je regarde monsieur le
ministre du Budget votre magnifique
document sur la croissance et l'emploi
je note qu'en 2013 hors pension hors
casse pension hors dette le budget de
l'État en 2013 était de 295 2 milliards
200 millions en 2014 il est 294 500
millions autrement dit il a baissé de 7
100 millions et la
dotation la diminution la dotation au
collectivité est exactement de 1
milliards en réalité c'est sur le dos
des collectivités territoriales que vous
avez ce mince bénéfice sur la croissance
des des dépenses du pays alors Monsieur
le l'intérêt de ces amendements pour
nous a le mérite d'éclairer crumement
vos vrais choix économiques fiscau il y
a une espèce de bonne taux fiscale avec
le cice pour les entreprises mais en
réalité dans l'état actuel des choses
c'est 10 milliards supplémentaire de
charges pour les entreprises c'est
presque autant de charges
supplémentaires pour les salariés et en
réalité c'est toujours privilégié la
consommation au profit de la production
donc de l'emploi le problème de ce
budget est qu'il manque curieusement
d'incitation et la principale incitation
qui lui manque c'est le courage
politique avec 57 1 du PIB de la payb en
dépenses publi tout en haut de la zone
euro vous vous asphyiez les forces
productives par rapport à l'Allemagne
qui est passée en 10 ans de 48,5 à
44,7 44,7 c'est un vraichisme qui se
prépare vous devriez pas en rire parce
que dans cet écart c'est les difficultés
de l'année des années qui viennent nous
avons des économies nous avons des
orientations trop divergentes pu que
nous puissions maintenir une monnaie
commune durablement en fait c'est un
budget conservateur sans cap ni courage
qui nous conduit au déclassement c'est
le vieux monde de la dépense incontrôlée
qui va s'écrouler avec le socialisme à
la française incapable de baisser la
dépense publique qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui mes chers
collègues c'est l'Espagne qui nous prend
des parts de marché notamment Indri vous
avez devant vous un budget à risque
budget budget à risque par rapport à nos
prêteurs internationaux un budget à
risque pour la paix sociale du pays vous
seriez
bien inspirer de garder un certain
nombre de nos de nos amendements
monsieur le ministre merci demande de
parole de notre collègue André Richard
as dit que nos amend avent été soutenus
par une partie de l'opposition monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues quelques mots simplement
pour abonder dans le sens vous n'en
doutez pas de notre collègue Francis
delâre ce projet de loi de finance pour
2014 présente en effet de très grandes
conséquences pour les entreprises
qu'elles soi toute petite ou qu'elle
soit un grand groupe international dont
le siège serait en France or ce sont
bien ces entreprises qui créent l'emploi
et cet emploi constitue je pense pour
tout le monde ici la priorité la
première des priorités pour notre pays
je passe sur les discussions que nous
avons eu Francis deâre est revenu sur
l'article 9 qui signe le retour de la
taxe à 75 % sur l'article 10 qui marque
un nouvel épisode de ce feuilleton de la
taxe sur le BE sur l'article 20 qui crée
une éco contribution
carbone pour m'étendre un peu plus sur
les mesures qui affectent tout
particulièrement les PME voire les
TPE la hausse de la TVA mise en œuvre
par les dispositions du plfrr pour PLFR
PLFR pour 2012 De décembre
2012 va donc entrer en vigueur le 1er
janvier prochain le gouvernement ne
souhaite pas revenir là-dessus pour un
produit de 6 milliards d'euros cette
hausse va affecter tous les secteurs
d'activité mais tout particulièrement
les artisstes dis an les commerçants et
on a vu encore récemment la grogne des
centres équestr illustre clairement que
tout le monde va être touché elle va
avoir des répercussions que l'on
n'imagine pas pour ces secteurs dont des
entreprises mes chers collègues peuvent
tous simplement disparaître parce que
leurs clients ne seront plus
solevables le bâtiment tout
particulièrement va beaucoup souffrir
puisque le taux est passé de 55 en 2011
à 7 en 2012 à 10 au 1er jan
multiplication par de en moins de 2 ans
dans un secteur qui emploie beaucoup de
maindœuvre qualifié à n'en pas douter le
travail noir va à nouveau
prospérer dans ce secteur il y aurait
certainement eu intérêt à faire
bénéficier les artisans indépendants
même si ce n'est pas la panacée du
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
j'avais eu l'occasion de le réclamer
malheureusement ce n'est pas le
cas l'article 23
bis a réduit lui de moitié le crédit
d'impôt apprentissage qui va pénaliser
les entreprises qui embauchent des
apprentis il est vrai que le
gouvernement préfère financer des
emplois d'avenir sur le dos du
contribuable l'article 24 lui baisse de
1,5 milliard d'euros la DGF des
collectivités on a le sentiment que ça
va pas toucher les entreprises vous
savez bien que non puisque c'est autant
qui sera compensé en impôts locaux donc
en CFE en VAE à la charge des
entreprises petites ou grandes et enfin
pour ne pas être trop long l'article 31
que nous avons vu hier soir baisse le
plafond des ressources affectées aux
compagnies consulaires vous l'avez vu de
façon drastique qui seront empêché de
réaliser leur mission d'accompagnement
des entreprise on le sait elle joue un
rôle fondamental qu'on le veille ou non
Infiné mes chers collègues le présent
projet de loi ponctionne 5,3 milliards
d'euros sur les entreprises et je ne
prends pas en compte l'impact de la TVA
sur leur activité cette hausse cela a
été dit tout à l'heure se rajoute à la
ponction de 10 milliards l'année
dernière ce sont donc 15 milliards
d'euros de prélèvement en plus pour les
entreprises vous permettrez de dire mes
chers collègues si vous votez si nous
votons cela ce sera 15 milliards de
moins pour l'emploi et la croissance
bien merci je suis saisi de deux
amendement le premier du gouvernement
qui tire les conséquences des votes
intervenus sur les articles de la
première partie le second de Monsieur
DEAE et plusieurs de ses collègues
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le Président je vais bien
entendu présenter ses amendements mais
je ne peux pas ne pas répondre aux
intervention extrêmement nuancée et
d'une grande honnêteté intellectuelle
que je viens d'entendre
et et donc et pour lesquels je voudrais
féliciter d'ailleurs très
chaleureusement leurs auteurs alors je
voudrais reprendre tous les arguments
qui ont été évoqués d'abord pour ce qui
concerne la dépense publique vous
inquiétez monsieur le séndateur de
l'augmentation de la dépense publique et
de l'augmentation des charges sur les
entreprises résultant de ce budget je
voudrais simplement vous rappeler des
chiffres qui sont dans les rapports du
au Conseil des finances publiques entre
2007 et
2012 non mais je comprends que ça vous
gêne mais enfin il faut savoir non non
mais monsieur sénateur il faut toujours
savoir d'où l'on part pour savoir dans
quelle direction l'on est et où s' prête
à arriver entre 2007 et 2012 la dépense
publique a augmenté de 170 milliards
d'euros lorsque l'on regarde ce qu'était
ce quiétait la part de la dépense
publique dans le produit intérieur brut
en 2007 et qu'on regarde ce qu'elle
était en 2012 elle avait augmenté de 3
points lorsque l'on regarde ce qu' a été
le taux d'augmentation de la dépense
publique entre 2007 et 2012 je vais même
remonter un petit peu plus lo entre 2002
et 2007 elle a été de 2,7 % entre 2000
de 2,3 % entre 2007 et 2012 d' 1,7 % le
budget qui vous est proposé là affiche
une division par 5 de l'augmentation de
la dépense publique et vous parlez
d'économie quand avez-vous fait des
économies lorsque vous étiez en
situation de responsabilité la révision
générale des politiques publiques é trit
votre doctrine la révision générale des
politique publique c'était 10 milliards
d'économie par rapport au tendantiel
d'augmentation de la dépense entre 2010
et 2013 et vous étiez à l'époque
occupant toutes les ondes de la
télévision et de la radio pour vous en
réjouir nous c'est 15 milliards en un an
seulement voilà la vérité concernant la
dépense publique avec un tel bilan vous
êtes bien entendu tout à fait légitime à
tenir les propos très nuancés que vous
venez de tenir ensuite vous dites
messieurs les sénateurs qu'il y a une
augmentation de 5,5 milliards des
charges qui pèsent sur les entreprises
cette année mais excusez-moi de vous le
le dire avec autant de franchise que
vous êtes exprimé c'est un colossal
bobard la réalité n'est absolument pas
celle-ci la réalité c'est quoi la
réalité c'est que nous avons mis en
place un crédit d'impôt compétitivité
emploi qui correspond à un allègement
net de charg de 20 milliards d'euros sur
les entreprises c'est 20 milliards c'est
20 milliards d'allèigement de charge sur
les entreprises c'est 7 milliards de
plus que la TVA sociale et alors que la
TVA sociale correspondait à une
diminution des cotisations sociales qui
avait principale caractéristique de
bonifier l'assiette de l'impôt sur les
sociétés si bien que vous récupériez par
l'intermédiaire de l'impôt sur les
sociétés une partie de ce que vous aviez
consenti en allèigement de charge si
bien qu'il aurait fallu faire 33
milliards de TVA social pour avoir 20
milliards d'allègement net de charg nous
nous faisons 20 milliards d'allègement
net de charge qui ne sont pas payés
intégralement par le contribuant
personne physique contrairement à votre
TVA sociale et ce crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi il est totalement
financé 10 milliards d'économie en
dépense donc 4 milliards dans le budget
2014 6 milliards de TVA et 3 milliards
de fiscalité écologique parce qu'il est
bon qu'une fiscalité vertueuse contribue
à l'abaissement du coût du travail voilà
très exactement ce que nous faisons et
j'ajoute que le niveau des prélèvements
cette année par rapport à celui de l'an
dernier est de 2 milliards inférieurs
nous prélvons 2 milliards de moins ce
qui veut dire qu'en 2014 l'allègement
net de charges fiscal et social sur les
entreprises est de 12 milliards quand
vous ind ch d'une augmentation de 5,5
milliards ça porte un nom c'est un
mensonge voilà ce que je voulais
indiquer concernant les propos que vous
avez tenu ensuite 3è point 3è point vous
indiquez prenant toute une série
d'exemples que nous aurions décidé
nous-mêm d'augmentation de fiscalité
vous avez pris monsieur le sénateur
l'exemple des centres équestre mais vous
êtes tellement peu convaincu de ce que
vous dites que lorsque nous avons voté
les amendements que vous présentiez
lorsqu'ils ont été votés par le Sénat
certains d'entre vous ont demandé des
suspensions de Séan tellement ils
étaient confrontés à une réalité simple
que je veux rappeler la réduction du
taux de TVA sur les centres équestres a
été décidé en 2004 alors qu'on savait
pertinemment qu'elle n'était pas
conforme au droit européen la Commission
européenne les institutions de l'Union
ont enclenché à l'encontre de cette
décision que vous avez prise une
procédure au terme de laquelle nous
avons été condamné au mois de mars 2012
vous n'en avez tenu aucun compte au
terme au terme de notre arrivée au
pouvoir nous avons cherché à convaincre
la Commission de la nécessité de
modifier un certain nombre de
dispositions de la directive TVA que
vous n'étiez pas parvenu à faire
modifier a été engagé à l'encontre de la
France en raison des décisions que vous
aviez prises et que nous avons essayer
de modifier une procédure de manquement
sur manquement au terme de laquelle si
nous procédions pas à une mise en
conformité du taux de TVA avec la
réglementation européenne nous nous
exposions à un risque financier
considérable au terme duquel nous
aurions été dans l'obligation de nous
mettre en conformité il est vrai que les
contentieux européens vous aimez ça
puisque dans le budget de l'an dernier
c'était plus de 3 milliards AUD dit du
contentieux au pcvm donc faire payer le
contribu à français pour les aements
juridiques dont vous avez été les
auteurs vous connaissez vous aimez nous
non c'est la raison pour la
nous avons décidé de nous mettre en
conformité au droit et c'est la raison
pour laquelle également nous engagerons
avec la Commission européenne dans le
cadre de la révision de la directive TVA
toutes les négociations qui doivent
l'être de telle sorte à ce que nous
puissions faire en sorte que les centres
équestre et d'autres activités puissent
bénéficier du T réuit de TVA ce que vous
n'avez pas réussi à faire voilà la
vérité que je voulais rétablir parce
qu'on la doit à la représentation
nationale quand on fait de la politique
avec des chiffr avec des réalités et non
pas avec de la mauvaise foi et des
propos tendancieux une discussion
budjétaire mérite mieux que cela vous
m'invitez monsieur le Président à
présenter l'amendement et je voudrais le
faire bien volontiers cet amendement du
Gouvernement est un amendement
traditionnel il est de nature technique
il vise à tirer les conséquences sur
l'équilibre budgétaire de l'ensemble des
votes intervenus au Sénat depuis le
début de la discussion de cette première
partie du PLF ces votes conduisent en
effet à revoir à la hausse le déficit
budgétaire de 10 milliards d'euros c'est
ça le résultat des amendements qui ont
été votés par un certain nombre de
groupes qui considèrent que la réduction
des déficits est l'objectif 10 milliards
d'euros de plus de déficit
euh résultant du rétablissement des
exonérations fiscales et sociales sur
les heures supplémentaires qui
représente rien de moins que 4,4
milliards d'euros il n'était é pas
financé lorsqu'ils ét mis en œuvre en
2007 ils ne le sont pas davantage
aujourd'hui de la suppression de
plusieurs mesures du PLF 2014 à hauteur
de près de 4 milliards il s'agit
notamment de la suppression de la baisse
de l'avantage procuré par le quotient
familial de la suppression de la taxe
exceptionnelle sur les très hautes
rémunérations de la suppression de la
baisse du crédit d'impôt apprentissage
de la suppression de laénagement des
taxes intérieures de consommation sur
les produits énergétiques du maintien de
l'exonération fiscale de la partie
iticipation de l'employeur au contrat
collectif et du maintien de
l'exonération d'impôt sur le revenu des
majorations de retraite ou de pension
pour charge de famille de la suppression
du malus automobile cette hausse de
déficit très significative j'en ai donné
le chiffre résulte également de la
modification de l'imputation des
intérêts d'emprunt à hauteur de 500
millions d'euros du rétablissement de la
demi-part supplémentaire des veuvres que
vous aviez supprimé au seul contribuable
vivant seul ayant eu à charge un enfant
pendant au moins 5 ans pour un coût d'un
,4 milliards de mesures d'aménagement
des taux de TVA à hauteur de 200
millions mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à l'issue de vos votes le
déficit budgétaire est ainsi porté à
92,6 milliards soit une progression de
10 milliards d'euros par rapport au
texte issu des débats à l'Assemblée
nationale l'ensemble des groupes
politiques converge vers l'impératif
c'était 14 si j'avais pas réussi à
freiner toutes vos ardeurs mais comme
j'ai un peu réussi ça fait seulement 10
l'ensemble des groupes politiques
converge vers l'impératif de
rétablissement des comptes publics et en
même temps nous constatons une impasse
budgétaire de 10 milliards incohérentes
avec les objectifs que vous avez
vous-même formulés dès lors la
responsabilité du gouvernement est de
présenter devant le Parlement un projet
de loi qui permet tout à la fois de
prendre en compte les intentions des
sénateurs et de garantir les objectifs
du gouvernement force de constater qu'il
n n n pas été euh possible et qu'une
majorité d'opposition s'est exprimé par
conséquent le gouvernement souhaite
procéder à une seconde délibération elle
permettra au groupe de la majorité de
pouvoir se prononcer le groupe
socialiste a constamment fait valoir sa
détermination à ne pas dégrader les
comptes publics tout en faisant valoir
les priorités du Sénat en terme de
solidarité de croissance et d'égalité du
territoire j'ai bien écoué les discours
introductifs des écologistes ils ont
retenu toute mon attention cette seconde
délibération permet de rétablir la
contribution climat énergie ainsi que le
rétablissement du malus automobile
rejeté en première délibération de même
ce projet de loi contient la TVA
innovation thermique qui est une
préoccupation historique de la majorité
des écologistes quant au groupe RDSE je
tiens à souligner en insistant l'esprit
de responsabilité qui a animé chacune de
ces interventions et si nous retenons
pas l'ensemble de vos propositions pour
des raisons que vous comprenez je
constate sur un grand nombre de sujets
une convergence de vue qui existe entre
vous et nous et qui porte à nom la
responsabilité je vous
merci l'amendement
477 présenté par notre collègue de lae
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
arrivons effectivement au vote de
l'article d'équilibre avec je le crains
l'impossibilité pour nous pour une deuxè
année consécutive de discuter de la
dépense je le crains parce que les
déficits continuent d'augmenter l'an
dernier du Bernard casenu le ministre du
Budget vient de demander une seconde
délibération un vote bloqué c'est-à-dire
qu'il estime que le texte a été
tellement modifié par le Sénat depuis le
début de son examen qu'il est
aujourd'hui méconnaissable si bien que
même les socialistes ne pourraient pas
voter pour ce texte qui il aa dit
entérine un déficit de 92,6 milliards
d'euros soit 10 milliards de déficit en
plus par rapport à la version de
l'Assemblée nationale Bernard casn
ensuite parler des nombreuses
suppressions euh qu'il y a eu au Sénat
donc le rejet de la baisse du cootient
familial celui de la taxe exceptionnelle
à 75 % celle de la réforme des
plus-values immobilières et puis
certains maintiens par exemple
l'exonération fiscale pour les heures
supplémentaire tout cela revient donc à
un texte méconnaissable son seul recours
possible c'est donc la seconde
délibération le vote bloqué c'est-à-dire
demander au séndateurs de voter non pas
sur le texte modifié amendé par les
sénateurs mais leur demander de voter
sur le texte du Gouvernement seulement
enrichi des amendements du rapporteur
général du budget c'est-à-dire un texte
avec lequel le gouvernement est d'accord
à 100 % voilà pour l'instant les
sénateurs poursuivent les discussions
après cette demande et c'est Vincent
deaet qui a la parole pour son
amendement sur l'article 43 initiative à
ce sujet d'une remise à plat de la
dépense publique alors pour vous aider
pour vous aider j'ai déposé cet
amendement effectivement avec certaines
N nombre de mes collègues pour essayer
de faire en sorte que nous prenions des
mesures réelles d'économie sur la
dépense publique pour vous les
économistes c'est de dépenser un petit
peu moins vite que ce qu'on faisait
avant j'ai compris dans votre
intervention précédente que vous
critiquiez la majorité précédente pour
l'augmentation des dépenses sur la durée
de la
mandature je pense que pour réduire la
dépense il faut vraiment la diminuer
et faire les efforts que vous proposez
pour les collectivités locales on n'est
pas opposé à des efforts pour les
collectivités locales mais moi je
souhaiterais que les efforts que vous
demandiez aux collectivités locales
c'estàd 100illard c'estàdire 3,6 % de la
dotation de l'an dernier que nous les
appliquions sur les dépenses de l'État
et si nous faisons ça nous récupérons
14,6 milliards d'euros donc les 10
milliards d'euros dont vous parliez tout
à l'heure ils sont largement comblés
monsieur le ministre donc nous sommes
disposés à travailler avec avec le
gouvernement pour donner des pistes on
en a donné on a donné le retour sur les
35 heur par exemple on a donné dans la
discussion sur les retraites aussi une
possibilité d'une vraie réforme des
retraites qui fasse diminuer la dépense
on pourrait aussi revenir sur les
rythmes scolaires qui nous ont été
imposés qui qui ont été imposés de façon
unilatérale et qui coûte 300 millions au
budget de l'État et 1 milliard au
collectivités on on n pas pensé à
supprimer l'école pas du tout monsieur
nerry mais euh je pense qu'il y a il y a
des dispositions courageuses que nous
pourrions prendre tous ensemble pour
diminuer réellement la dépense publique
et permettre de retrouver une situation
saine de nos finances publiques et
d'éviter de systématiquement solliciter
le contribuable voilà l'objet de du
présent amendement monsieur le Président
bien je vous remercie sur ces
amendements quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général
qui monsieur le présid président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
euh s'agissant tout d'abord de
l'amendement du Gouvernement à l'article
d'équilibre vous noterez que c'est un
exercice particulier puisqu'il s'agit de
retracer fidèlement l'impact des votes
du Sénat sur l'équilibre du budget de
l'État et cet amendement n'a donc pas de
portée politique mais simplement
informative voire pédagogique s'agissant
d'un article de récapitulation la seule
question qui doit se poser s'agissant de
notre vote et donc celle de savoir si
vos services monsieur le ministre ont
fidèlement retracer l'impact des votes
intervenus au Sénat depuis jeudi après
l'avoir rapidement examiné je n'ai pas
de doute à cette égard et vous invite
mes chers collègues à voter cet
amendement même si vous l'aurez compris
cela ne signifie nullement une
quelconque caution de ma part sur les
votes intervenus à ce jour à ce ce
moment de la discussion je ressens au
contraire comme sans doute un certain
nombre de collègues une certaine
frustration devant un projet de loi de
finance qui n'a plus de cohérence compte
tenu des majorités de circonstances
fluctuantes qui ont marqué notre
discussion les apports du Sénat se
trouvent dès lors quelque peu noyés dans
cette confusion dans ces conditions il
est heureux que nous soyons invités par
le gouvernement dans quelques minutes à
nous prononcer sur un texte qui s'il ne
nous permettra sans doute pas de passer
à la seconde partie permettra au moins
au Sénat de se prononcer sur un projet
cohérent j'avais formulé le vœu lors de
la discussion générale que notre
discussion soit marquée par la cohérence
et par des des propositions
constructives j'avoue être un peu déçu
même très déçu certes je comprends que
l'opposition puisse s'opposer à des
mesures
prise
individuellement mais pour autant
j'avoue ne guerre comprendre le sens de
certains votes s'agissant par exemple
des taux de TVA de la part de groupes
politiques qui ont il y a pas si
longtemps voté et défendu des
augmentations très conséquentes de la
TVA et qui ces jours derniers ont voulu
nous donner la leçon sur ce
sujet le résultat de ces votes mes chers
collègues le résultat de ces votes c'est
une dégradation sensible du solde
budgetaire de l'état de plus de 10
milliards d'euros et si on ajoute les
comptes sociaux puisqu'il y a aussi une
répercussion au niveau des des
prélèvements sociaux nous arrivons
effectivement aux 14 milliards dont
quelqu'un parler tout à l'heure je
comprends que nos collègues de
l'opposition nous disent qu'il convient
de baisser les dépenses on vient de
l'entendre à l'instant et on va bientôt
être dans l'époque des et nos enfants
petits- enfants vont certains d'entre
eux demander une baguette magique à
l'occasion des cadeaux de
Noël voici un bel exemple de baguette
magique parce que notre collègue de la
nous dit si on diminue les dépenses de
14 milliards et ben on améliore le sold
voilà baguette magique et c'est
bon vous ne pas avoir eu l'occasion de
voir ni dans cet hémicycle ni en
commission des finances ni ailleurs de
propositions clair argumenté sérieus
réduisant ces dépenses d'une quinzaine
de milliards d'euros supplémentaires par
rapport aux efforts que nous effectuons
déjà ne faites pas croire que la
réduction des dépenses serait simple ou
indolore au moins autant que les
dépenses fiscales elles ont leur utilité
leur histoire leur défenseurs mais il y
a une ch qui doit prévaloir sur toutes
les autres celle de notre crédibilité de
notre trajectoire des finances publiques
c'est l'engagement que nous avons pris
devant les Français et devant nos
partenaires européens aujourd'hui pour
assurer la cohérence du projet de loi de
finance le gouvernement ne peut faire
autrement que nous demander d'adopter en
bloc la première partie nous y viendrons
tout à l'heure dans cette attente je
vous invite à adopter cet amendement non
pour des raisons de fond je l'ai
expliqué à l'instant mais afin de
prendre acte des votes du Sénat et de
leurs conséquences euh dans un une
dimension tout à fait mécanique des
choses enfin je voulais donner l'avis
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances ou de son rapporteur
général sur l'amendement de Monsieur
delae dont j'ai déjà parlé il s'agit
avec cet amendement de réduire de 14,67
milliards d'euros la dépense du budget
général de l'État à l'article
d'équilibre du projet de loi de finances
et euh comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire au cours de la discussion générale
il serait sans doute plus utile de
nourrir le débat avec des propositions
concrètes que de s'en tenir à des
pétitions de principe mais cet
amendement traduit cet amendement
traduit peut-être aussi la frustration
de certains de nos collègues devant le
risque de ne pouvoir porter de telles
initiatives dans la seconde partie du
projet de loi de finances mais au fond
il n'est pas trop tard mes chers
collègues il n'est pas trop tard que
d'aller vers ce travail à dit détaillé
fructueux de la seconde partie et je
vous invite donc à bien réfléchir avant
d'émettre votre vote tout à l'heure très
bien je vous remercie avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre sur
l'amendement de Monsieur
de monsieur le sénateur de la vous nous
invitez à travailler avec vous sur la
réduction des déficits et la diminution
de la dépense et vous prenez des
arguments pour nous convaincre que je
veux rappeler un les déficits augmentent
alors je vais vous rappeler quelle est
la séquence des déficits lorsque nous
sommes arrivés en situation de responsab
en 2011 c'était en
2011 non mais en 2011 le déficit était
de 5,3
% en 2012 il était de
48 en 2013 il sera de 41 et le projet de
budget qui vous est proposé le ramène à
36 donc si je comprends bien votre
raisonnement monsieur delay quand on
passe de 53 en 2011 à 36 en 2014 les
déficits
augmentent dans l'arithmétique telle
qu'elle m'a été enseignée quand on passe
de 53 à 36 il diminu donc dès lors que
vous considérez que lorsque les déficits
diminuent ils augmentent vouloir les
diminuer avec vous c'est se condamner à
les augmenter donc je ne peux pas pour
cette raisonl accéder au raisonnement ça
ça vaut pour le déficit nominal mais si
je prends le déficit des comptes de la
Sécurité sociale je vous donne les
chiffres 20,8 milliards en 2011 17,5
milliards en 2012 16,2 milliards en 2013
et 12,8 milliards en 2014 donc quand on
passe de
28 à
128 on augmente les déficits donc compte
tenu de ce que de ce qu'est la
conception de l'arithmétique qui préside
à votre intervention je préfère m'en
référer à la conception qui est la nôtre
et continuer à diminuer les déficits
avec la majorité plutôt que de les
augmenter avec vous deè point vous
proposez une remise plat de la dépense
publique vous avez raison euh
entre 2007 et 2012 170 milliards de plus
de
dépenses depuis que nous sommes en
situation de responsabilité le rythme
d'augmentation de la dépense publique a
été divisé par 4 par 5 même puisque
c'était 2 % et c'est 0,4 en 2014 et nous
faisons 5 milliards de plus d'économie
en 1 an que vous n'en aviez fait pendant
les 3 ans de la révision des général
général des politiques publiques vous
dites mais ce sont des économies par
rapport au tendantiel d'augmentation de
la dépens mais les économies de la
révision générale des politiques
publiques étaient aussi des économies
par rapport au tendantiel d'augmentation
de la dépense je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que la Cour des comptes comme
la Commission européenne mesure les
efforts structurels des États à partir
des efforts faits par les États en
économie au regard de ce qui est le
tendantiel d'augmentation de la dépense
mais je comprends que tout le
raisonnement qui est le vôtre consiste à
considérer que depuis qu'une majorité
nouvelle est au pouvoir il faut que tous
les instruments de mesures budgétaires
soient cassés de manière à bien apporter
la démonstration que les efforts
supplémentaires qu'elle fait par rapport
à ceux qui l'ont précédé n'existent pas
donc cette remise à plat des économies
nous la faisons nous allons continuer à
faire ces économies en dépenses et je
dois dire monsieur le monsieur le
sénateur que je ne suis pas convaincu
qu'il faille beaucoup compter sur vous
pour le faire puisque'en l'espace de 4h
samedi l'opposition a augmenté la
dépense publique et la dépense fiscale
de plus de 10 milliards d'euros donc
permettez-moi de conclure en vous disant
que s'il faut maîtriser les dépenses et
réduire les déficits je préfère me
m'appuyer sur cette partie de
l'hémicycle que sur
celle-là merci alors en explication de
vote sur ces amendements monsieur
carucci après vous souhaitez par vous
intervenir tout de suite monsieur le
Président si vous le souhaitez avec
l'autorisation de nos collègues merci
beaucoup monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues la polémique n'est pas
absolument
indispensable il me semble il me semble
monsieur le
ministre il me semble que nous
pouvons continuer à nous écouter
réciproquement et je
voudrais pour ma
part tâcher de
répondre à ces critiques que vous ne
cessez de faire depuis vendredi sur les
votes que nous avons
émis chacun
connaît les règles constitutionnelles et
de procédure qui s'appliquent à l'examen
d'une loi de financeces ou la 5e
République l'initiative parlementaire
est limitée et et au demeurant une
commission des finances en est la
gardienne puisque le jeu de l'article 40
de la Constitution rend particulièrement
difficile à certains égards il faut
peut-être s'en féliciter mais rend peu
lisibles les initiatives des
parlementaires dans l'examen d'une loi
de
finances monsieur le
ministre vous avez dit et je le conçois
bien que vous
préfériez vous appuyer sur cette partie
de
l'hémicycle certes c'est assez évident
mais si si les votes ont été ce qu'ils
ont été c'est quand même bien la
démonstration que vos appuis vous ont
partiellement manqué un certain nombre
de fois pardonnez-moi de le dire c'est
l'explication
arthmétique des votes que vous avez
enregistré donc il ne serait pas
absolument équitable il serait même faux
de
n'incriminer que cette partieci de
l'hémicycle à la
vérité si j'essaie de regarder les
chiffres nous avons en
effetti et quelques instants creuser le
déficit de 10 milliards d'euros environ
c'est ce que nous dit votre amendement
de
totalisation
mais depuis que vous êtes en charge et
j'en ai fait la liste vous avez
alourdi très
sensiblement les dépenses publiques vous
avez pris des initiatives et c'était
bien votre droit d'une certaine façon
c'était l'alternance mais des des des
initiatives qui
engage la responsabilité politique du
gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez le décret permettant le
retour intégral à la retraite à 60 ans
pour certaines carrières longues c'est
de l'ordre d'1,3 milliard d'euros en
14 les 500000 contrats de génération
c'est 1 milliard
d'euros les mais laissez-moi aller
jusqu'au bout vous pouvez tout à fait
revendiquer ces mesures il est de mon
devoir de dire que ce sont des dépenses
supplémentaair que nous n'aurions pas
faite les 150000 emplois d'avenir c'est
3,4 milliards d'euros les 60000 postes
dans l'Éducation nationale c'est 9
milliard d'euros par an la
revalorisation du SM c'est 570 millions
mais je vous en
prie monsieur le Président est-ce que
Monsieur Président je vous en prie
continuez de l'endroit où je me trouve
je nentends que vous voilà mais mon
propos ne sera pas long merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président de vre équité dans
la conduite de nos débats je vous en
remercie vivement donc
si je passe sur une série de choses la
hausse de 25 % de laallocation de
rentrée scolaire c'est 400 millions
d'euros par an 5000 postes
supplémentaires dans différentes
administrations autres que l'éducation
nationale 200 millions la suppression du
jour de 40 157 millions
et et tout cela sont des estimations
pour
2014 la réforme des rythmes scolaires si
l'on raisonne au niveau de l'ensemble du
secteur public c'est plus d'un milliard
d'euros avec toute la liste que je vous
ai donné nous sommes au niveau de la
dizaine de milliards d'euros et je
n'englobe pas là-dedans le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi qui est
différent de la TVA sociale que nous
avions faite puisque celle-ci était
équilibrée il s'agissait d'un
redéploiement dans une enveloppe fermée
alors que le
cice fera
apparaître un risque pour l'équilibre
budgétaire si les économies que vous
annoncez ne peuvent pas se faire à ce
niveau-là et et si la fiscalité dite
écologique n'arrive pas au rendez-vous
et ce n'est pas une chose simple à
hauteur de 4 milliards d'euros donc
monsieur le ministre peut-être est un
hasard des choses mais finalement les
quelques 10 milliards d'euros de
majoration que nous
avons réalisé par nos votes et bien cela
se compare tout simplement aux dépenses
supplémentaires que vous avez faites ce
qui veut dire que certes nous aurions
continué à exonérer les heures
supplémentaires de charg sociales et de
fiscalité mais nous n'aurions pas fait
toute une série de dépenses que vous
avez décidé de réaliser donc sur le
thème de la maîtrise des comptes publics
et de la
maîtrise des déficits publics et du
respect de nos engagements ne
caricaturez pas ce que nous avons fait
parce que vous ne preneiez en en en
compte dans votre comparaison qu'une
partie seulement des choses voilà donc
je me permettais simplement de dire cela
et bien entendu de façon symbolique en
ce qui me concerne personnellement je
souscrirai à l'amendement de Vincent
delay merci de votre
attention merci la parole est à présent
à Monsieur Roger
carou monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais être nettement plus
bref parce qu'après l'intervention
remarquable du président de la
commission des finances tout est
dit je je voudrais juste dire monsieur
le ministre
et monsieur le rapporteur n'est plus là
mais enfin du CAL monsieur le Président
vous savez en la matière vous savez
faire beaucoup avec votre
gouvernement donc restons
calme la vérité elle est où elle est que
lorsque le rapporteur général dit il
faut regarder le tendantiel tendanciel
pardon de vous le dire monsieur le
ministre vous le savez très bien mais on
l'a dit c'est la responsabilité d'un
nouveau pouvoirs vous arrivez en 2012
nous nous étions sur un une tendance
permettant la baisse du déficit en 2012
en 2013 en 2014 en 2013 en 2014 j'ai
écouté tout le monde avec attention la
vérité c'est que très logiquement un
certain nombre d'engagement du candidat
devenu
président vous tenez certains en tout
cas des engagements ce sont des
engagements qui coûtent c'est comme ça
vous créez des emplois dans l'éducation
nationale vous annoncez les contrats
d'avenir vous dites que vous revenez
vous on interrompt quelques instants
cette séance cette discussion autour de
l'amendement de Vincent de et puis après
la seconde délibération demandée par le
gouvernement sur la première partie du
projet loi de finances pour 2014 pour
faire un peu un point sur cette séance
avec Jean artui sénateur centriste
ancien président de la commission des
finances du Sénat bonjour jeanartu merci
d'être avec nous donc le Sénat qui va
trèsem probblement rejeter la première
partie de ce budget 2014 on entendait à
l'instant cette querelle de chiffres un
peu veine finalement autour du niveau
des déficits publics à partir du moment
où les sénateurs ont venté des
amendements un peu dans tous les sens
qui ont dénaturé ce projet de loi de
finance pour 2014 non oui exercice est
une
gesticulation
vaine et finalement
dérisoire le pays traverse une crise
dont la
gravité suscite l'exaspération les
angoisses dans tout le pays nos
concitoyens attendent d'autres réponses
je pense que nous devrions apaiser ce
climat politique pe dire que depuis
plusieurs décennies et la droite et la
gauche ont échoué tout le monde a à sa
part de responsabilité mais il y a pas
non plus de grandes coalitions gauche-
droite qui se mettrai et qui est prête à
se mettre d'accord sur une politique de
finances publiqu au moment où Madame
Merkel vient de scellerler une grande
coalition alors qu'elle est sortie
victorieuse au terme d'une campagne
difficile on peut dire que sa victoire
était brillante et bien en dépit de cela
ils ont l'humilité de se rassembler nous
sommes à l'heure de la
mondialisation alors qu'ici en France
mais la gauche et la droite h ont
continué sous l'empire de l'État
providence à dépenser plus à atteindre
un niveau de dépenses publi exorbitant
et à concevoir une fiscalité dont la
complexité est extrême et le montant
extravagant puisque 46 % du produit
intérieur brut fait l'objet de
préléements obligatoires mais personne n
d'accord sur les solutions à apporter je
déplore que que que le Sénat soit à
point dans l'incapacité de prendre une
position claire tout ceci parce qu'il y
a une majorité de gauche mais il y a pas
de majorité pour soutenir le
gouvernement alors moi j'attendais du
président du Sénat qu'il y ait la
recherche d'échange de discussion pour
trouver un consensus pour être en mesure
d'apporter une valeur ajoutée dans le
débat parlementaire sur les grandes
questions que sont la compétitivité la
réforme des retraite et ne pas camper
dans nos camps respectifs avec cette
incapacité à aller de de l'avant à faire
preuve de lucidité et de courage c'est
pant ce qui va se passer notamment sur
la réflexion en ce moment sur la
fiscalité tout le monde monte son groupe
de travail dans son coin y compris les
députés socialistes qui réfléchissent à
l'Assemblée les sénateurs socialistes
ici au Sénat l'UMP dans son coin aussi
donc c'est un peu vain là aussi comme
exercice non ce qui est pathétique c'est
que monsieur hérro est au pouvoir depuis
18 mois et après 18 mois d'initiative et
de veines réformes voilà qui nous
propose une remise à plat qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que tout ce
qui s'est fait depuis 18 moi est à jeter
à la poubelle est incompréhensible et
contraire aux objectifs que doit
poursuivre notre pays je pense qu'il
faudrait apaiser ce climat et se mettre
d'accord sur un certain nombre de de
préalables comment retrouver de la
compétitivité comment cesser d'accabler
la production par des impôts qui font
que à l'URE de la globalisation de la
mondialisation on va produire ailleurs
forcément donc nous avons à nous
remettre en cause et les arguments qui
échanges ici sont quand même très
formels et relèvent beaucoup plus de la
gesticulation que d'une attitude
responsable alors en tant qu'ancien
président de la commission des finances
du Sénat expliquez-nous ce qui va se
passer là dans les minutes qui qui vont
suivre le gouvernement a demandé une
seconde délibération sur la première
partie de de cette loi de de finances
seconde délibération qui va sans doute
être rejetée par le Sénat et après
l'article d'équilibre la partie recette
va être rejetée à votre avis par le
Sénat je le crois je crois et je le
regrette et pour ma part je ne
participerai pas au vote car j' préféré
que l'article d'équilibre fut voté pour
pouvoir examiner les crédits de la
deuxème partie c'est-à-dire les crédits
des différentes missions et surtout ce
qu'on appelle les articles rattachés
parce qu'il concerneent directement les
collectivités territoriales il y a des
dispositions relatives aux péréquations
et des de mon point de vue peu
admissible h que le Sénat n'est pas
l'occasion de se prononcer sur ces
questions s'en remettre totalement
puisqu'on va envoyer une copie blanche à
l'Assemblée nationale sans remettre
totalement à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
c'est un aveu assez pathétique de la
part du Sénat est-ce que vous êtes comme
certains de sénateur de de l'opposition
qui trouve que le climat est un peu
déprimant ici au Sénat puisque personne
n'arrive à se mettre d'accord sur un
texte et que en tout cas les les textes
phares les projets loi phar comme le
budget de la Sécurité sociale ce projet
loi de de finances et puis d' a texte
sur les retraites également soi tous
rejetés par le Sénat je trouve ça
extrêmement préjudiciable il y a ici une
expertise qui n'arrive pas à s'exprimer
donc je cherche vainement la valeur
ajoutée du Sénat dans les travaux
législatifs est-ce qui n'est pas
possible ici au Sénat et et c'est le
reproche que je fais au président du
Sénat il y a pas si longtemps il
exprimait sa satisfaction au terme de la
de la première
session réglementaire mais enfin est-ce
qu'on pour pourit pas ici nous ne sommes
pas prisonniers du fait majoritaire
comme nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
sortir des clivages partisan des des
éléments de langage qui font qu'on tire
tout vers le bas et en caricaturant la
la démarche politique est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas ici convenir de grandes
orientations il n'y a pas d'initiative
dans ce sensci hélas non et je le
regrette profondément je ne pense pas
que le président du Sénat qui
probablement souhaite donner un coup de
main au président de la République je ne
pense pas que le Parlement doiv se
montrer complaisant à l'égard du pouvoir
quel qu'il soit et et surtout quand on a
le souci d'assurer la réussite d'un
gouvernement je crois que le le
Parlement doit être exigeant et en
aucune circonstance complaisant c'est
l'intérêt du pays qui est là en cause
moi j'entends la la désespérance qui se
manifeste ici et là et j'ai le sentiment
que parlementaire j'ai les plus grandes
difficulté pour apporter une petite
valeur ajoutée dans le débat afin qu'on
puisse s'en sortir et rompre avec nos
tradition qui relève beaucoup plus de la
gesticulation que d'une attitude
responsable bon ben écoutez on va
repartir en séance on va bien voir ce
qui va se passer ce soir ici au Sénat
mais c'est effectivement assez vu c'est
à nouveau Vincent de la sénateur de de
votre groupe qui s'exprime donc on va
suivre après les explications de vote
sur cette première partie du projet loi
de finance pour 2014 ainsi que le vote
et le rejet par le Sénat de ce budget
merci Jean artui on repart en séance on
se retrouve ici ensuite avec d'autres
invitations c'est ça qui nous pose
problème il y aurait une majorité claire
pour le gouvernement avec une opposition
claire ou une majorité d'opposition
claire nous pourrions faire des
propositions et les faire adopter par le
par l'Assemblée donc aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas le faire et c'est ça qui rend
compliqué notre notre travail ici et on
a l'impression d'un Sénat chamboule tout
un petit peu pour ce pour cette lo de
finance
malheureusement je pense que c'est la
configuration de notre assemblée et
l'absence de majorité clair pour le
gouvernement qui rend cet exercice très
difficile ici au
Sénat parole à notre collègue Éric
Boquet monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègu et pourtant il a
bien une majorité de gauche arithmétique
dans cet
hémicycle sur l'amendement de notre
collègue Vincent de à qui je reconnais
effectivement le mérite de la cohérence
de ces prop
depuis que je l'entends mais il ne fait
qu'aggraver évidemment la logique que
nous combattons depuis le début de la
discussion dans ce PLF 2014 vous le
savez nous l'avons dit dans la
discussion générale au cours de la
discussion des amendements et à cette
heure-ci de la même manière cette
proposition donc c'est la réduction des
dépenses publiques de manière drastique
c'est quelqu parcelle de de la facilité
réduction des dépenses publiques se
rapprochant de plus en plus de
l'incantation qui est devenue vraiment
incontournable et nous ne pouvons pas
trancher entre les deux options qui nous
ont faite ce soir d'autant plus facile
que courageux mais non téméraire nos
collègues se contentent comme cela fut
déjà observé dans cette assemblée entre
1997 et 2002 de procéder à une coupe
arithmétique des dépenses publiques
prenant par la même bien le soin de ne
pas spécifier ni préciser dans quel
domaine et sur quel chapitre budgétaire
il serait question de réaliser ces
coupes claires tout simplement parce que
toute chose égal par ailleurs les
dépenses publiques de l'État une fois
mises de côté les dépenses de personnel
les crédits évaluatifs notamment ceux de
la mission remboursements et
dégrèvements et quelques autres ne
laissent pas énormément de Marg de
manœuvre que faut-il réduire mes chers
mes chers collègues et puis faudrait-il
en conclure que ces dépenses n'auraient
eu aucune utilité les crédits des aides
au logement au risque de priver les gens
d'une partie de leur pouvoir d'achat et
de générer de nouveaux contentieux
locatifs faut-il réduire les crédits de
la location adulte handicapé au risque
de laisser plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes sans ressources
les entreprises ne respectant pas plus
que cela leurs obligations d'embauche
faut-il réduire les crédits destinés à
aider les communes ayant à mettre en
œuvre les nouveaux rythmes scolaires
faut-il supprimer les crédits de ceux
qui vont payer le 10e mois de bourse
étudiante ce prévu pour rembourser la
TVA aux artisans et commerçants et
cetera vous voyez aisément mes chers
collègues que l'exercice de coupe clair
dans la forêt des crédits budgétaires
est loin d'être facile à moins que la
facilité soit précisément comme nous
l'avons indiqué d'afficher une volonté
dont on sait pertinemment qu'elle ne
sera jamais suivie desffits or je crains
qu'à ce stade vous nayz oublié deux
choses mes chers collègues dans cette
logique 1 une bonne part de la dépense
publique est réalisée aujourd'hui par
des opérateurs par les collectivité
locale et n'apparaît donc pas
directement dans ce budget 2 ce qu'il
faut réduire et interroger de manière
déterminée c'est la masse énorme de la
dépense fiscale nous pensons là qu'il y
a du grain à moudre je vous remercie
très bien je vous remercie je vais
mettre au voie l'amendement 545 du
gouvernement ceux qui sont favorables
lève monsieur le rapporteur général
pardon mes chers collègues vous avez la
parole oui je je reprécise une nouvelle
fois je reprécise une nouvelle fois à
nos collègues que cet amendement c'est
un amendement qui a une nature
essentiellement comptable hein le débat
politique va venir après la suspension
dans quelques minutes ici il s'agit de
du constat comptable de l'ensemble des
conséquences comptables donc des
amendements qui ont été voté au Sénat
sur la configuration globale donc de ce
projet de ce budget pour 2014 donc ça
une dimension comptable et la commission
des finances recommande donc le vote
c'est disposition mécanique le vote donc
de cette conséquence en fait de tous les
votes intervenus ici et je recommande
donc le vote contre pour l'amendement
présenté par notre collègue de alors
j'en reviens à l'amendement 545 du
gouvernement après ces explications ceux
qui sont favorables lève la
main
merci ceux qui sont
contre
abstention l'amendement est adopté en
conséquence l'amendement 477 de Monsieur
delae
tombele je mettre voticle
1 très bien alors je vais mettre au voix
l'article d'équilibre l' l'article
pardon
est-ce que je peux considérer que le
vote est le même même vote même
vote merci il est
adopté nous avons donc terminé l'examen
de la première partie la parole est à
présent au
gouvernement bien monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs en
application de l'article 43 alinéa 4 et
de l'article 47 bis alinéa 1er du
Règlement du Sénat le le gouvernement
demande qu'il soit procédé à une seconde
délibération sur les articles 6 B a 6 b
b 6 B C 5 Quinquis 7 sexis 7 septis 7
octis 10 bis 12 12 bis 12 terr 13 19 bis
22 bis 24 terr 29 bis 31 34 bis et par
coordination sur l'article 43 et la TA a
annexé au projet de loi de finance le
gouvernement souhaite également rétablir
les articles 3 5 6 8 bis 9 18 20 23 bis
et 37 qui ont été supprimés par le Sénat
en outre conformément à l'article 44 alé
3 de la Constitution et à l'article 42
al 7 du Règlement du Sénat le
gouvernement demande qu'il soit procédé
à un seul vote sur les amendements de
cette seconde délibération ainsi que sur
l'ensemble de la première partie du
projet de loi de
finance merci mes chers collègues euh en
conséquence à l'application de l'article
47 10 alinéa 1 du règlement le
gouvernement demande au Sénat qu'il soit
procédé à une seconde délibération sur
les articles indiqués la seconde
délibération et de droit lorsqu'elle est
demandée par le gouvernement
conformément à l'article 43 al 5 de
notre règlement lorsqu'il y a lieu à
secondde délibération les textes adoptés
lors de la première délibération sont
renvoyés à la commission qui doit
présenter un nouveau rapport nous allons
suspendre la séance pour
permettre oui laissez-moi terminer chers
collègu suspendre la séance pour
permettre à la Commission de se réunir
et je prends donc le rappel au règlement
de madame la Présidente Hian Assassi si
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mon rappel
au règlement se fonde évidemment sur les
termes de l'article 36 de notre
règlement relatif à l'organisation de
nos travaux après l'annonce donc par le
gouvernement de recourir à la procédure
dite de vote bloqué alors si je
comprends bien le travail d'amendement
la controverse des idées et les
conclusions les conclusions du débat
tout cela est balayé d'un trait de plume
ou presque comme si rien de ce qui s'est
dit dans cette enceinte depuis jeudi
n'avait existé
donc cette manière de faire qui devient
quand même assez habituel ici au Sénat
puisque nous l'avons déjà observé lors
de la discussion de la loi de finances
2013 de la
présumée loi de sécurisation de l'emploi
de la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale cette manière de faire ne peut
me semble-t-il constituer l'alpha et
l'oméga de la discussion parlementaire
au Sénat alors notre ligne dont le le
ministre mais pas simplement celui-ci
présent d'autres qui nous ont fait le
plaisir d'être parmi nous tout au long
de débat ont souligné la
cohérence de ce que nous disions ce dont
nous leur donnons acte volontiers mais
notre ligne a consisté à l'occasion de
ce débat à faire valoir des mesures que
nous considérons favorables au pouvoir
d'achat de nos concitoyens il se
confirme selon de nombreux analystes que
nous allons enregistrer une nouvelle
baisse du pouvoir d'achat des ménages
évitons donc que la ponction fiscale
inconsidéré ne viennent s'ajouter au gel
des traitements des fonctionnaires et au
désastreus tique de modération salariale
encouragé par les exonérations de
cotisation sociale ces exonérations font
trop souvent office de politique de
l'emploi dans notre pays nous avons
estimé que les entreprises bénéficiaires
de plus de
165 milliards d'euros dettes fiscales
diverses et certains ménag détenteurs
d'importants patrimoine générateurs de
plusvalue immobilière et mobilière
pouvait fort bien faire quelques efforts
pour pour aider au redressement des
comptes publics nous avons déposé des
amendements en ce sens qui même quand
ils ont éveillé la tentention n'ont pas
cru de voir recevoir l'accord du
gouvernement je n'aurais pas l'audace de
rappeler par trop souvent les mots de
François Hollande sur la nécessité de ne
pas entamé par une trop forte pression
fiscale le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
les discours de campagne électorale
étant parfois d'imprudent Paris sur
l'avenir mais le fait est que ce sont
les ménages les consommateurs ce sont
les mêmes d'ailleurs qui vont être
fiscalement parlant mis exclusivement à
contribution les entreprises vont
pouvoir sans qu'il ne soit l'espace d'un
instant exigé d'elle la moindre
contrepartie continuer de tirer parti
des 165 milliards d'Es fiscales des 30
milliards d'exonération de cotisation
sociale mais aussi des aide budgétaire
direct prévu par la loi de finances vu
le résultat cela ne me semble pas être
monsieur le ministre le bon choix à
force de ne de ne pas pouvoir faire
partager ses
priorités au demeurant discutable vous
voici donc conduit vous aussi au vote
bloqué alors jeoudraai vous dire
Monsieur le Ministre
cessz cessz avec le groupe socialiste de
vous enfermer dans
l'erreur merci acte donné de votre
rappel au règlement madame la
Présidente je vais maintenant donner la
parole à Monsieur carucci pour un rappel
au
règlement même fondement monsieur le
Président sur l'article 36 naturellement
sur l'organisation des travaux
parlementaires c'était juste un petit
mot d'humour pour rappeler que lorsque
j'étais en charge des relations avec le
Parlement j'ai souvenir avoir ici même
je parle pas à l'Assemblée mais ici même
demandé au terme d'un texte de loi
important une deuxième lecture sur un
article et j'avais eu droit à comment
dire une bronca de l'ensemble des
groupes à l'époque de l'opposition
aujourd'hui majoritaire pour dire c'est
absolument une violation du Parlement
c'est scandaleux le gouvernement ne
respecte pas le Parlement à quoi ça sert
qu'on est passé 24 heures à débattre si
après et au terme de tout ça vous
revenez là-dessus sur un article j'étais
confus et penau je constate que le
ministre du Budget est beaucoup moins
que moi quand il fait 15 articles 10
milliards et qu'il dit en fait au Sénat
vous avez bien fait de rester là jour et
nuit depuis jeudi bonne soirée messieurs
dames merci nous allons donc suspendre
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances quelle durée prévoyez-vous
pour cette suspension de séance Monsieur
le
Président d'un côté c'est vrai comme il
y a de très nombreux
articles nous pourrions revenir sur le
fond de chaque sujet mais comme comme
c'est une question en réalité très très
globale et que tout a été dit espère que
10 minutes un quart d'heure au plus
seront
suffisants très bien merci pour 10
minutes la séance est
suspendue
par voilà donc suspension de la séance
pour 10 minutes vient de préciser
Jean-Pierre Bell réunion de la
commission des finances Jean Vincent
placé qui fait partie de la commission
des finances est à mes côté donc vous
alle vous allez devoir
en réunion bon le groupe écologiste que
vous présidez ici au Sénat va s'abstenir
sur ce projet de loi de de finance est
une position que vous assumez oui tout à
fait cela fait plusieurs mois presque
même ces 18 derniers mois que nous
essayons d'alerter le gouvernement sur
l'excessive austérité et l'excessive
rigueur des budgets qui sont présentés
on n pas fait et je salue d'ailleurs
l'initiative du Premier ministre à cgar
mais on n pas fait la grande réforme
fiscale que nous appelions no vux ce qui
fait que nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui en plus à euh finan là vous
devz être satisfait avec les annonces de
Jean-Marc her oui quelque part j'espère
d'ailleurs que cette abstention sera un
solde du passé parce que ces deux
derniers budgets nous ne les avons pas
soutenu avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme
parce que mesure phare le crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi dont on voit bien
la globale inutilité même les
entrepreneurs le disent maintien du
budget militaire sanctuarisé alors qu'on
voit bien les besoins des services publ
aussi bien sur l'écologie que sur la
santé que sur la recherche donc une
priorisation qui nous paraît contestable
et donc je l'ai dit les augmentations de
TVA déjà le taux de 20 % mais aussi les
taux de 7 à 10 qui s'abattent pour le
coup aussi sur les PME PMI et en
particulier sur des produits écologiques
dont les transports collectifs les
déchets la question des bâtiments donc
oui mais on voit bien que l'équation est
impossible à gauche c'estàdire que
personne n'a les mêmes positions
personne n'est d'accord sur rien donc
l'équation est totalement impossible
entre les communistes les Verts et le
Parti socialiste non il fallait assumer
déjà la grande réforme fiscale
c'est-à-dire qu'on a déjà pris 2 ans de
retard faire en sorte que justement on a
un débat non pas seulement sur le
consentement de l'impôt mais sur S sa
réhabilitation si jeose dire son utilité
pour financer des investissements pour
le coup d'avenir et on a fait je vous le
dis l'erreur du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi on se retrouve à
l'augmentation de TVA on aurait pu avoir
une autre donne beaucoup plus dynamique
en matière budgétaire et fiscale si on
ne s'était pas complu à rester dans les
clous d'une part du traité européen et
d'une espèce de peur des marchés qui
tétanisent et moi j'en appelle à une
politique plus volontariste et y compris
d'ailleurs sur les budgets liés aux
collectivités territoriales moins 1
milliard et demi pour les collectivités
territoriales nous en plus on ne fait
pas là-dessus du de la démagogie on
était pour la suppression des conseils
généraux nous sommes pour trouver des
économies mais ces économies elles sont
aussi des éléments si on vous écoute
bien on voit pas très bien vous voulez
les trouver les économies puisque vous
vous refuser toutes les économies
souhaitées par par le gouvernement que
ce soit la ha et TVA par exemple de la
TVA madame PID c'est pas c'est pas une
économie la haose la TVA c'est une
recette et sur les questions budgétaires
donc réforme de l'État on aurait pu
essayer de réfléchir au poids excessiv
d' l'administration centrale vous voyez
donc c'est pas une petite mesure c'est
c'est c'était porté dans le temps par
Michel Rocard et on ne revient plus sur
ces sujetsl la réforme de la
décentralisation on a rajouté la
métropole à l'ensemble des strates que
nous avions alors que nous assez
courageusement nous pensons que il
fallait concentrer sur les
agglomérations et sur les régions et
donc supprimer les conseils généraux
voilà ça c'est pas une petite mesure et
d'ailleurs qui allait peut-être pour le
coup plus dans le sens de nos
prédécesseurs et quand je vous parle de
budget militaire c'est pas moi qui
ferais le pacifiste bélan non c'était la
proposition de Bercy de diminu le
militaire paye quand même pas mal il y a
beaucoup de suppression de poste de non
renouvellement de de poste la loi de
programmation militaire est tout même
assez sévère non oui tout à fait mais
c'est le vent de l'Histoire pourquoi
continuons-nous à avoir des des casernes
si j'ose dire tourner vers l'Est de
l'Europe c'est la vraie réalité et moi
je suis pas du tout un pécifiste bélan
comme je vous le disais je pense que
c'est extrêmement important d'avoir une
force d'intervention digne de ce nom
bien plus significative quand on voit je
salue nos militaires qui sont au Mali et
aujourd'hui en centra-afrique mais quand
on voit les nécessités notamment de la
police internationale les nécessité
d'une forme de droit d'ingérance
internationale on a besoin de plus de
soldats en en force de d'intervention
directe et beaucoup moins en statique
donc voilà il fallait assumer des choix
courageux qui je vous le dis ce sont pas
c'est pas moi qui proposais ça c'est
Jérôme Cahusac et même les services de
Bernard caseneu donc voilà on a voulu
sanctuariser ce budget on baisse le
budget de l'écologie on baisse le budget
compris de la recherche on baisse à peu
près l'ensemble des budgets et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans
une situation comme on n' pas fait cette
grande réforme fiscale et qu'on s'est
placé sous les clous de la
rigueur à vous écouter on se demande
finalement pourquoi vous ne votez pas
contre effectivement le débat pourrait
avoir lieu mais il s'avère que nous
sommes dans la majorité
pour le coup vu la situation politique
et compris une forme de marasme
politique dans lequel nous sommes
quitter le navire gouvernemental je
crois que ce serait pas y compris même
convenable en réalité il faut
s'accrocher et c'est en ce sensl que
j'espère que ça sera un solde du passé
et que justement l'initiative que qui
commence demain d'ailleurs avec les
groupes parlementaires du Premier
ministre que je rencontre à 11h pour lui
parler la réforme fiscale nous permettra
d'envisager budget futur sous un plan de
plus de justice et réellement vers le
redressement merci beaucoup Jean vin
placer je vous laisse rejoindre la
commission des finances puisque
effffectivement suspension de séance
avant le vote des sénateurs sur la
première parti de ce projet de loi de
finance pour 2014 suspension de séance
puisque la Commission des des Finances a
demandé à se réunir avec la seconde
délibération demandée par le
gouvernement th tranui vous êtes dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat vous suivez
précisément cette séance importante
aujourd'hui pour nous dites-nous ce qui
va se passer euh quand après la après la
réunion de la commission des finances
quand la séance va reprendre alors on va
déjà faire un petit retour sur ce qui
vient de se passer c'est-à-dire la
demande de seconde délibération par
Bernard casenuve le ministre du Budget
alors il a dit et bien cette ce budget
enterrine un déficit de
92,6 milliards d'euros plus de 10
milliards d'euros de déficit en plus
dans la version du Sénat par rapport à
la version de l'Assemblée le ministre du
Budget l'a dit il ne reconnaît plus ce
budget ce budget a été complètement
détricoté complètement modifié tellement
amendé par les sénateur qu'il est
impossible pour les socialistes
eux-mêmes de voter ce budget alors parmi
les grosses suppressions les gros
changements on peut noter le rejet de la
baisse du cootient familial celui de la
taxe exceptionnelle à 75 % pour les
rémunérations supérieures à 1 million
d'euros celui de la réforme des
plus-values immobilières le Sénat qui en
revanche a maintenu le taux réduit de la
TVA pour les centres Castres contre la
vie du gouvernement ainsi que
l'exonération fiscale pour les heures
supplémentaires bref le texte était
complètement méconnaissable le
gouvernement risque de se retrouver face
à un sénat unanimement contre son seul
recours possible c'est donc le vote
bloqué c'est-à-dire demander au sénateur
de voter non pas sur le texte amendé
modifié complètement chamboulé par le
Sénat mais sur le texte du Gouvernement
enrichi par les seuls amendements du
rapporteur général c'est-à-dire un
budget conforme à ce que voulait le
gouvernement euh on va rappeler que ce
n'est pas la première fois euh que le
Sénat a recours à cette procédure faire
un petit retour en arrière il y a
quelques semaines il y a eu la réforme
des retraites ici le texte était
tellement méconnaissable euh que et bien
il y a eu une unanimité contre les
socialistes eux-mêmes ont voté contre
leurs propres texte euh puisque celui-ci
n'était plus du tout conforme à la
version du gouvernement puis et bien il
y a eu l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 on se retrouve face à une situation
proche c'est-à-dire que le texte est
tellement modifié que là encore les
socialistes vont avoir beaucoup de mal à
pouvoir voter pour le texte et bien
cette fois-ci Marie soltoren sort cette
arme du vote bloqué cette arme qui lui
permet donc de faire voter le les
sénateurs sur le texte du Gouvernement
enrichi des amendements du rapporteur
des affaires sociales et finalement on a
arrive un rejet du texte mais avec tout
de même les voix socialistes on va
certainement se retrouver dans cette
même situation cette fois-ci sur le
projet de loi de finances 2014 puisque
au moins cela va permettre donc d'avoir
ici les voix des socialistes alors après
donc cette suspension de séance et après
la après la réunion de la commission des
finance et bien les sénateurs vont se
réunir à nouveau dans l'hémicycle et
cette fois-ci ils vont donc entamer ce
que l'on appelle les explications de
vote ils vont prendre la parole les uns
après les autres chacun par groupe pour
pouvoir expliquer donc son vote sur ce
texte donc et après ça il va y avoir un
scrutin public ordinaire un scrutin
public à avoir lieu donc derrière moi
dans l'hémicycle il va y avoir des urnes
qui vont être déposé donc à la tribune
et chaque groupe va pouvoir déposer son
vote pour contre ou abstention voilà
perine ce qui va se passer dans quelques
instants merci beaucoup Tom pour ces
explications complètes très détaillées
alors effectivement on va attendre la
fin de cette réunion de la commission
des finances je vous propose en
attendant un reportage on va se rendre
dans la circonscription du sénateur
alberériic de Montgolfier sénateur UMP
c'est un reportage un focus autour de
l'installation d'une grande station
solaire et du photovoltaïque et on se
retrouve après ici en direct de la salle
des conférences à tout à l'heure